number seven how will count carbon
nanotubes change from my life well I
didn't Hosea London I don't know how old
you are but some they're not going to
change you that a lot at the moment erm
I I think I may be wrong a very clear on
one thing you learn about sizes that you
are wrong a lot of the time but I think
the first applications of nanotubes will
probably be encompass of materials where
control of size and structure will not
be quite so important but for the
paradigm shifting applications that we
know are possible whether the probable I
don't know I think we'll have to have
very close control of structure now I
don't know that we have that but I'm one
of two of my friends say they've got
some breakthroughs if you've got very
good controller structure and they're
all the same then you get a coordinated
effect imagine you have a bunch of
straws in the box and you open the box
up and you see that hexagonal packing of
the ends of the straw and you've put
very very weak glue on the each straw
then you you stick them all carefully
together you'll have an incredibly
strong material not only that what
really restricts the application of many
materials or defects now if you have the
defect in one strong one straw as you
know little bit tall it won't propagate
to the next strong and that's a magic
property of this material at the
molecular level
I have trees have that I mean the tree
is striated I mean though they're weak
this way but they're very strong that
way so we should be able to make perhaps
the most amazing material I've ever made
if we can control the synthesis of
carbon nanotubes very closely and make
them very long at the moment we can make
a bundle of a hundred maybe a few
microns long but we need to make them
yards long and in bundles of 10 to the
15th as a say what is 10 to 15
a hundred thousand million million
something like this in a bundle and they
will have Van der Waals forces holding
them together so that could be a massive
breakthrough and that would change our
lives because we're built to build
bridges so so strong they won't fall
down in earthquakes and airplanes so
like that they won't they glide if the
engines fail we could probably make a
car that when you crash it won't break
up it would be so strong and light and
that would be good especially as you
have come into actually you could you
can take this car be so light then when
you come to a crossing you wouldn't need
red lights because you'd be
radio-controlled and they would go down
you go over the top and if you hit
they'd be black with mantra constantly
but the fan that'd be good and that
would change your life but just imagine
it no red lights at intersections
I think that would be well worth it so
the other possibility is that if we can
solve the molecular electronics problem
that nanotubes could well be the linkers
are the current conductors in molecular
electronics and that would be good again
that requires the chemical synthetic
breakthroughs with some weight off that
and of course if we can really solve the
problem making cables with nanotubes the
this would be fantastically effective
for electrical conduction on massive
scale it's not a superconducting but it
would be zero
let lost conduction so there are
possibilities but before that happens I
think there really will have to be some
big big chemistry technology
breakthroughs